I'm gonna boil down a lot of that and
you'll see you've got the main sense
there okay but the only company is one
two three four five words force is
proportional that's all for a sec now I
know there are some slight more nuance
is going on in Newton's second law okay
but this is enough for our purposes
remember mathematically we're viewing
this this very sort of an idealized
world okay so that's okay just because
something is idealized doesn't mean it's
a mean that's more useless actually it's
super super useful because then you can
actually solve the done thing as opposed
to if you were thinking about all of the
intricacies and complexities that you
don't even understand you can't solve it
you can't actually work with it but I
can get from this enough to actually you
know solve a problem and work out what's
going on as you'll see in a minute okay
so um our mathematical way to beat the
pants off of this is to say equals yeah
okay now again so there are a few
nuances here they're like the way you
describe force you also see it sometimes
written but F is not equal to Ma but F
is proportional to Ma right you've seen
a proportionality symbol before
now can I get the science to you it
really doesn't matter which one you see
because mass is a constant that will
where we're talking about objects that
do not spontaneously increase or
decrease in mass okay so therefore if
you say F is equal to Ma or M is
proportional to M a because in itself is
a constant it doesn't matter right it
just gets factored into that constant in
the same way if you got a string of
indefinite integrals right
all the big constants you can say all
those constant constant constant
constant you can just put them in one
pile and say there's one constant that's
an end okay you don't lose any
information it's all still in it
okay now we need to at this point we
need to talk about some units so the
unit of force is the Newton right
because we are want to this guy
so one meter
wonder even I should say that some of it
one not in okay can someone talking
about the definition of evolution of
forces how much force isn't it's enough
force to do what now then another now
they think this right it's kind of like
a differential statement okay so you are
a force over here it should make sense
to you that there's going to be a mass
and acceleration over here right so for
sends into Newtons what matter we can
talk about one kilogram okay so it's one
kilogram accelerated at one meter per
second per second okay
so this is what a Newton is this is what
we define as a new right so just pay
attention because sometimes the
questions will be given to you in terms
of acceleration in which case you don't
worry about meetings in kilograms and
other times we will be given to you in
terms of forces so pay careful attention
because you'll be off my fiber depending
on the mass of the object begin all
right I think that's all I wanted to say
about second
now the third law has a very famous and
PP sort of summary statement of it and
I'm going to boil it down even further
than that because I just wanna have as
little as possible to remember I got
five words again yeah I got five words
forgive my English are boiled down
version of Newton's third law of motion
is that actions have can someone tell it
called opposite reactions and of course
the arm the various poetic way of saying
it is that for every action there is an
equal and opposite reaction which is
love later rolls off the tongue just all
these extra words in there are these
conjunctions okay so if I have grilled
down a little bit it doesn't roll off
the tongue as nice up as nicely but it's
okay no for me it's always I always need
a picture in my mind right so the two
pictures that I always like cuz yeah
it's okay running now what's going on is
we are when the swimmer is moving
through the water
I can't maybe you in fact once you I've
embarrassed yourself okay when you've
gotta swim up okay now this super is
moving forward moving but how is it that
they are creating forward motion and the
answer is here thank you they are
pushing the water they're pushing the
water backwards so the water is reacting
and pushing against them
does that make sense so that's what
creates
this change in movement it's a safe deal
with a product how is it similar and how
is it different
yeah very good sir so this is why in
fact I'm even going to do this maybe you
want to do this as well when a runner
begins at the Olympics right they don't
just have a standing start what do they
do they've got they've got blocks right
now think about this now what's the
point of the box what's the point of the
box look at them look I can't because
because you want to go forward you don't
want to go right so therefore if you can
angle the force of your jumping off in
this direction further in the opposite
direction so let me draw it up right
this way
rather than like say this way do you see
which way the reaction force is going to
go the same amount of energy you propel
you more in that direction than just
just simply upwards okay so I can set
equal opposite reactions yes exactly
right so if you look closely you'll see
it is precisely the same yeah no I'm
wearing our wedding the father though I
should say before before those books did
get their angle and that extra bit right
how did they do it
yes so number one you stand on the edge
so your jump sort of goes that way and
also you've got your you've got your
whole like your whole body is moving
forward right so you got your arms which
actually propel you that way and so
that's why your mission it goes